hey guys welcome back to another episode
of the swoosh what led podcast for
anyone who's new to the podcast swish is
an awesome platform where you can get a
video message from some of your favorite
sports stars it is the ideal gift for
someone especially anyone out there who
idolises a sports star i even got my own
one last week from someone i'm loving
watching play one of my favorite players
at the moment big peter garcia cooler
and i absolutely love it i can also get
you 10 percent discount off your
purchase with the code what a lad and
believe it or not up to 70 of all
proceeds go to kiwi kids charities which
is the best bit of it all
i'll leave a link in the description so
that you just have to click on that also
if you want to see my message from big
peter garc head over to the wadelette
instagram page and it'll be up there so
you sort of get an idea of what it's
like
also before we start i have the great
tim bateman here with me
to tell you about this exciting
opportunity that he has for all
waterlogged listeners cheers jimmy
are you looking for an exciting career
for life after rugby my name's tim
bateman and i've been a professional
rugby player for the last 17 years
my plan for life after rugby was to get
into the well-being and recovery
industry so i built ostudio new
zealand's largest well-being and
recovery centre o studio has given me a
career option where i can take advantage
of the skills i've built through rugby
it works for my family it lets me own my
own time and it's given me the financial
freedom i need to do what i want with my
life despite the challenges of covert
we've seen consistent growth in our
business and we've decided to expand
ostudio throughout new zealand and
abroad
it's an exciting time for the wellbeing
industry and we're looking for top lads
to be a part of it by opening your own o
studio
if you're interested head to ostudio dot
co dot nz slash lad to inquire or send
me an email at tim ostudio dot co dot nz
back to the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh what a lad well there'll be a lot of
you happy with the guest i have on today
as i've had plenty of requests to get
this led on he's had a hell of a career
today after starring for canterbury
winning all sorts with the crusaders and
even achieving what every kiwi kid
dreams of in becoming an all black last
season he headed up north to the mighty
manoa 2 turbos where he was one of the
best players in the comp and he is
currently over in japan playing for his
beloved kamaishi sea waves and on top of
all that by all accounts he's one of the
greatest lads around it is the champion
man brett cameron welcome mate
g'day jimmy night cheers for having me
cheers for the intro
a big big fan of the show always tune in
and listen to a few good yarns so
stoked to be on mate appreciate you
coming on fitting it into your busy
japanese schedule over there i
understand you've got a week off but
you're still getting absolutely hammered
yeah it's a bit different i'm getting
used to the training load over here
we're yeah still flat out in the bye
week but that's all good and avoiding
contact
yeah just being smart still in those
contact drills just getting on the edge
a few double fuses second shoulders in
there that'll do me
mate how you how you're finding it over
there in a hole how you're finding the
lifestyle and um life in japan yeah it's
not too bad i um i love japan it's an
awesome
awesome place to live um and the people
here are awesome so
it's been a cool experience so far
didn't realize um sort of how far away
kawaiishi was initially it's way up
north so
it's a it's a quiet little town so
there's not a lot to do here but i've
been trying to get out of out and about
a wee bit and you've got a good group of
foreigners there obviously the people's
champ sammy henwood and morgan mitchell
as well if he's anything like his
brother scratcher he'll be a lad as well
yeah a couple of absolute lads so it's
um it's awesome to have those boys just
to kick around with and
and talk some [ __ ] with the training and
how you're finding the footy like it's
obviously a different style and
different level to what you've been
playing
yeah it's it's a lot different um the
team's been struggling quite a bit so
it has been a wee bit frustrating and
still kind of
getting used to dealing with that i
guess but you just gotta um adjust and
get used to i guess a different way of
of playing but it's still
still enjoyable and still um having a
good time just hopefully we can
get a few good results in this back into
the season yeah and running the cutter
at 10
with all japanese players around you i
know i personally struggled with that
but how are you going your japanese or
nihongo must be pretty fluent
far from it i've dabbled in a few
lessons to try but it goes out the
window when you're on the field
um
yeah still getting used to sort of
coming around the corner and it's just
crooked outside yes so it's a bit
different but
it's still good
have you got a translator with your team
one of the halfbacks is our translator
so
it's handy when he's on the field but
sometimes when
if he's not playing it's sort of you try
chipping in the huddles but you don't
really know what
what's going on and what's just going
straight over their heads
yeah stuff at times
and stephen donald mentioned about the
kick pressure over there how hard it is
for a tent to try and apply his kicking
game to on a game without the kick chase
but have you found that over there as
well
yeah listen to that and i was cracking
up
i've had a few similar scenarios for
sure
but
sort of just trying to keep the ball in
hand a bit more anyway
and did you just sign a one-year
contract was that yeah just over here
for the season yeah because there was a
lot of talk around
um a lot of super rugby teams wanting to
get you out of this contract after your
season with manoa too how close were you
of getting out of the contract uh yeah
it was a bit of a tough one sort of
tried to look at it a little bit but um
unfortunately it's just a bit late in
the piece i didn't want to pull out that
late and i was pretty committed to
coming over here and it was a bit
unfortunate the timing would have loved
to stay in new zealand but still it's
been a an awesome experience coming over
here not bad for the wallet either
yeah it's yeah not too bad definitely
not not
channing what some of those big boys are
down in tokyo
yeah that's true the d-max of the world
oh they're taking it all for everyone
but your plans still to come back to new
zealand you're back with manoa too and
then see what happens you filled up your
pockets and hoping to give super rugby a
crack next year is that is that sort of
the goal yeah
i'm back with one or two really looking
forward to that and
yeah that's that's my goal at the moment
i want to you know play super rugby
again i guess coming over here sort of
reconfirmed that for me that i i just
really want to compete at a high level
and test myself i guess
prove to myself that i can um compete
you know at super and i'd love to get
the opportunity so
we'll see what happens what teams were
after yeah
all of them
[Laughter]
nah there's only sort of one that had a
crack in the end but yeah it was just a
bit too late and is that the team you're
potentially looking to go to next year
or you're just going to see how the
season goes and then assess it later in
the year yeah i think i sort of just
have to see how it goes um obviously
can't control what what those teams are
thinking at the moment and they've got
some quality tens and all when all the
teams playing and a good competition at
the moment so
just gotta um wait and see and hopefully
i can still put my best foot forward um
if there's still time i had exciting
stuff exciting stuff for new zealand
rugby to have you back in the game over
here but as always i know you're a
listener so like to go back to what it
was like for all my guests growing up so
i don't know too much about your
upbringing but pretty keen to hear it
yeah awesome um yeah grew up in
mighty wanganui
had awesome childhood
um just just grew up around sports all
the time dad was a keen
uh sportsman and it was just
sort of rugby all winter and cricket all
summer pretty much through
all of my schooling and had an awesome
bunch of mates and a lot of family in
wanganui so it was a it was an awesome
place to grow up how did you go at
cricket uh not too bad i um
used to just bet and and keep a little
bit
played uh just a lot of club cricket and
and wanganui and
made a few rep teams
through the grades and absolutely loved
it still love it haven't played in a
while but i'm always watching on on
telly and yeah i was lucky enough to
sort of play for wanganui men's team for
a few years so that was
um good fun were you you would have been
coming through the same age grades as
julie barrett were you yeah yeah we
played together uh central districts
under 17s so
we used to play against each other when
we were younger as well when he was
playing for the nike so he said i had
him for his first suck so i'll take that
tried to pull
a bump of the grub at a short little
fella who's probably not as much higher
than the stumps
so center miles away
[Laughter]
and then you followed him down to uni
down at lincoln uni wasn't it
yeah um
he has a bit of a late call
going to uni uh down in lincoln and i
didn't really
have many mates that i knew going but i
knew geordi was going so it was
it was awesome to have him down there
and we sort of just kicked around
together for the first
few weeks until we found our feet were
you living with him um yeah we were both
in the halls first year and then
we lived together our second year uh
flirting i think he mentioned it on here
as well we're in a flat of seven um
in our second year
it was a good time sounded like you guys
got up to all sorts sounded like loose
times
i don't know how he played um
npc that year the way he did
considering our living
situation and were you were you in the
npc squad at the time or were you
playing club rugby at this stage no i
was just playing um club footy yeah
played a few uh canterbury b development
games but i'm just playing for lincoln
is that the mighty rams yeah sure is
mate give me the rundown of life as a
ram it sounds like it's one of the great
times lots of questions came in about
the mighty ram
yeah it's awesome um
still love going back and playing for
them it's awesome playing off those boys
and it's pretty cool now
obviously when we were young we got to
play with a few crusaders and stuff that
would come back so
now being on the other side of it it's
it's so cool to make some mingle with
those young boys and see
they're still getting up to mischief
like we used to but we always had a it
had a really strong side out there so it
was good footy and it was good fun do
you just come back and dominate the
court sessions and stuff
nah
i don't know if i want to see what's
going on in there now i don't know
hopefully it hasn't gone any worse but
um
i went back to one
initiations and it's
as crooked like yeah
it still haunts me i was so scared going
into it as a
as a wee 19 year old
what you have to do
probably don't want to say half of it
but
yeah it's just
yeah all sports
so when did the switch flick that you
were gonna try and give professional
rugby a go when did you think this was
an opportunity for you um actually not
till
i left school
cricket was my main sport pretty much
all the way up until i left high school
but in my final year of school i made a
couple of
camps with the hurricane schools and new
zealand schools so
after that
experience of sort of like a higher
level when a bit of a professional
environment um
i sort of thought you know this is what
i'm keen to do
after that
i think
i was playing some decent rugby
uh cults my first year that was that was
awesome
um but it still seemed like a long way
away i remember watching the div one
team and thinking geez hopefully i
play this before i leave uni but um
made the under 19s and then we uh from
there sort of a couple under 20s camps
and then
that was when i sort of really wanted to
push on and
once i got into the crusaders academy
that was a big step up and
sort of gives you a taste of of what you
need to do to make a a professional team
and that was
probably the best place to be for it um
so i learned a lot and just wanted to
keep keep getting better and how did the
canterbury call up come about
i actually signed a
a development contract with tasman
that yeah did you um
so i was about to head up for
they wanted me to go up and play club
rugby
up there and um in the end i sort of
just had to ask the coaches and stuff
like what are the what are the chances
of me actually getting a full contract
out of this or or playing and it was
pretty low so i i ended up pulling pin
and just staying
in christchurch for club rugby played a
couple of the rand philly shield
uh preseason games and
and win it right and then ended up uh
getting a contract from that so
i worked out in the end true did you
feel comfortable playing in those games
those van fully shield games did you
feel
like you were good enough
uh yeah i i think so um basically the
whole team was was club players at the
time so
i felt like i was playing some pretty
good club rugby and it was it was pretty
cool made my debut
for canterbury against wanganui hometown
in a shield game so that was pretty
pretty crazy growing up always wanted to
play for the butcher boys and then
playing against him so
that was awesome true and then what
about when you made your debut in a um
mpc match yeah that was uh awesome
feeling and
it definitely felt like a massive step
up just the pace and the
physicality
but that year was
probably still one of my most enjoyable
years we had an awesome team ended up
winning that that year in 2017 but i got
a not too much game time but i started a
couple of games and
just little
cameos off the bench here and there and
just
i guess i was sort of just not thinking
too much that year and just plain
instinctive and and i really enjoyed it
and is that when you got your call up to
the crusaders after that season um no i
didn't i i just did a pre-season uh with
them after that uh first year yeah
but uh
ended up being on the bench for a couple
of games and playing one just as injury
cover
i think richie was injured and maybe
mike delaney had a hit away niggle you
mentioned richie there obviously he's
recently come on the podcast but someone
you've been behind a lot throughout your
career you mentioned not getting too
much of a run in the canterbury squad in
2017. obviously he was running the
cutter then
um pretty much through your whole
crusaders time there was that man in
front of you as well so
what was it like being under him uh
what'd you learn from him what's he like
yeah he's awesome hey we're we're really
good mates now and
um it was so cool coming in and um he
was someone i looked up to so
to sort of just shadow him for
for a few years and especially that
first year and just
i didn't say too much just sort of
followed and and watch what uh how he
prepared and
i guess what what goes in during the
week for his performance on the weekend
so
that was awesome but yeah at times like
it's it's a tough act to follow um he's
he's such a good team man like when he's
when he speaks everyone you've run
lessons and he's he's a bit of a joker
so
there was like a bit of pressure i guess
and just in my own head at times like
having to stand up in front of the team
after after someone like that um was
pretty tough initially and what about on
the field as well obviously off the
field he has this persona that everyone
respects what about on the field with
the performances he obviously
has driven that side round very well for
obviously the past five or six years and
every time you get the opportunity is
the expectation the same yeah
he's awesome obviously you see what he's
done in the last few seasons of super
rugby he's
he's a crazy um player and um very smart
and the way that he can deal with
scenarios out there so i learnt a lot in
that respect
and just i guess just had to
try and take my opportunities um
when i got the chance and you obviously
did because
a big moment in your career was when you
were named for the all blacks talk me
through that whole experience from your
point of view yeah it was it was pretty
crazy initially um
i'd only
played
uh one year one game that year for the
crusaders um and was just playing npc
and i think
remember that the team naming that they
were they were doing that big 50 man
squad for the northern tour for that
japan game and i i was really keen to
tune in just to see if any
like any boys i knew were gonna make it
yeah um but never never thought that i
was a chance and we're out training and
then
our coach brought us into the team room
after training and he sort of just
rattled off all the boys that were were
getting picked and we were we were
stoked for guys like bridgie drummo and
and stuff that hadn't been there before
and then my name was last and
i sort of paused for a second i had to
see if he was being serious and
uh the boys sort of just erupted and it
was um
it was a bit of a whirlwind but it was
it was awesome and just going into that
environment
after a good npc campaign was
like just topped off an awesome year and
it was um
yeah an unreal experience yeah that's
crazy i know a lot of guys say they
weren't really expecting their name to
get rid out when they when they're
sitting down and watching it but like
you said you'd only played
one
super rugby game so i could imagine you
were literally shocked when that when
your name was read out
yeah big time head
yeah no idea whatsoever
and did you feel comfortable going in
the environment
uh probably not like
um it was it made it a lot better having
lots of good mates
um in there having geordie and
um the cannery boys and i roomed with
richie all week so that made it a lot
easier for me and i think the coaches
sort of
made that week quite uh relaxed for us
obviously it was a it was a pretty new
team and we only had a week to prepare
so
there wasn't too much
going on that week but it was crazy
initially just going into and sitting in
the team room and and looking around of
the boys that were in there you know
that's where you want to be and it was
it was pretty awesome yeah and then talk
me through the game you're obviously
playing against japan you're on the
bench um what do you like on the bench
you're a nervous wreck or you're all
good
for some reason that that game i wasn't
nervous at all i was sitting there like
i'm way more nervous playing for lincoln
than i am here at the moment so it's a
bit weird
but i guess it's tough like when you're
a 10 on the bench you're usually the
last one to get on so you just
you get to that stage when you're like
oh come on i just want to get out there
yeah and just sort of take it off but um
i think it was about seven minutes or
eight minutes to go and
got the call to to get out there and i
was just really excited to get out there
and
and have a crack um unfortunately only i
think i touched the ball once were just
on defense i didn't get to do too much
and it went by pretty quick what a touch
that was though
yeah i think i got a bit lucky there i
was just ran a line off richie as the
ball was going into touch i either i was
either going to get let up or go through
and thank god i went through
oh one of the greats you're probably so
relaxed that you're probably more
nervous about the haka before you sat
down on the bench were you yeah yeah 100
you always sort of wonder like if the
boys practice it and stuff but we did
like one little low-key run through but
i guess you you do it in front of the tv
you definitely know it like as you're a
kid so
but i was more nervous for that actually
like looking up at the big screen i was
like
geez what's going on here
get the camera off me
no poo counters over here
[Laughter]
yeah but ethan said that he learnt his
off youtube so is there a little bit of
truth to that you actually only sort of
do one quick practice yeah one little
captain's run i guess just in the hotel
i think yeah maybe we just did it
because there was so many new boys that
were all but nervous about it so did you
did you know the hacker already just
from what you'd seen before yeah yeah
pretty much like uh
i knew we'd probably do the the old one
and i think
yeah steve said during the week he's
like yeah
we'll do the old boy
[Laughter]
pretty much knew it and then post that
game talk to me about what life was like
for you post that game i felt like you
copped a fair bit of criticism for your
selection potentially did you feel any
backlash from being named yeah a little
bit um
but initially like i didn't think about
it i i came home back to
back to christchurch for a bit back to
the races enjoyed my summer off the
with the flatties down there and back
home so that that was good fun but i
sort of knew coming back that
yeah i was going to get a bit of stick
but
it is what it is it always happens and
i guess like
parents and good mates and everything
sort of just reassured me that
you know that doesn't just happen you're
picked for a reason so i just had to to
believe that and um
yeah i didn't feel like i went out with
with too much pressure the following
year but
at times i probably did get a little bit
in my own head about it and just just
wanting to perform and then the
following year same situation for you
didn't get a huge amount of game time
from memory still sitting behind richie
yeah it's tough um
yeah sort of just getting five minutes
off the bench here and there and i guess
at a stage i sort of got into a bad
mindset of
um looking back it's
it's a shocking mindset but at times you
feel like
when you come on for five minutes the
game's already won and and all you can
really do is kind of stuff something up
so yeah it was tough sort of just being
in those situations more often than not
and but that's on me like you just got
to be ready to take your opportunities
and yeah unfortunately that year didn't
didn't go too well did it ever cross
your mind to change franchises or you're
always pretty comfortable down there
happy in that crusaders environment uh
yeah it did a little bit um
but i actually didn't i didn't have any
sort of opportunities come my way to to
move
but but definitely thought about you
know i want to go somewhere to have a
crack at
being the starter um that was that was
always the goal and then talk to me
about the move up to manoa too the
mighty turbos yeah it sort of came up
just after
yeah the 2020 npc season i sort of sat
on the bench for most of it and
um i just sort of felt like i had a lot
more to offer um than what i was getting
that year and
yeah initially i wasn't too keen to move
i wanted to keep going but um
just saw it as awesome opportunity for a
for a change like i hadn't had change
since
i moved from school like i had always
been in christchurch so
it was a good opportunity to challenge
myself and a new team and i guess just
game time was a was a massive part of it
like just being in the saddle and
being able to sort of grow
as a leader and and run a team and you
obviously did that straight away massive
influence on the turbos how'd you find
it once you were up there yeah i loved
today awesome bunch of lads and it was
it was awesome for me just being close
to home it's just 45 minutes down the
road so
i think that benefited me a lot as well
just being back with
family and friends and
sort of gave me that time to just head
home and switch off from footy at times
but yeah going there i just wanted to to
earn the respect of the boys and i think
once i
felt like i was i was going all right
then
i was able to sort of step up more as a
leader and
keep growing my game and growing the
team did you feel like there's pressure
on you coming into the side being
probably the marquee signing the ten did
you feel extra pressure around that
um initially
like i sort of thought
about it but i was just really excited
to go and didn't
didn't really feel any pressure once i
went up there it was sort of the
opposite and it just it just came back
to having having fun again and just
really finding the enjoyment and
i think that always just shows um when
you're playing your best you're just
having fun and not not thinking too much
and you mentioned there's a fair few
lads up there as well you've got the
likes of chippy lamb mitchell and all
these roosters up there who love having
a good time so no doubt you fitted in
well
you probably hung out with him a wee bit
too much
but you didn't get to experience the
bucket heads at full force um obviously
covered
put a dampner on there but mate this
year hopefully crowds are back and
you're going to get to experience the
bucket heads up in that corner winding
your home oh fingers crossed
there's a few up there for one game but
yeah we need to get them back out in
full force maybe chippy will come back
for a holiday from italy and get them
going oh
they could do with jeffy to return as an
inspirational leader definitely i could
imagine you would have been a bucket
head back in the day too if you were up
there probably if i was in palmy never
really supported the two of those they
were just sort of always just wong and
away have you got any ambitions to play
for wanganui at any point um yeah yeah
i'd love to
um
no real like ambition but if if the
opportunity came up at the end of my
career like i'd i'd love to do it
and there's there's actually heaps of
boys playing like super and stuff now
and when we're home we always talk about
it like there's
sam malcolm tarantino waitoki who played
for one or two and they're over in
america yeah they want to do it at some
stage and then there's stevie pirifita
joan enrique villamonica roy so
we always talk about
if we could all get out on the field for
wanganui at one stage that would be good
stuff
imagine that
might be a shield defense pre-season
shield affair
try get it back down in the heartland
oh imagine that that would be loose
but what are your plans other than
coming back to new zealand um have you
got much of a goal for sort of the next
five years have you
you're keen to get you're keen to give
new zealand rugby another crack you
sound like you've got unfinished
business here yeah haven't got like too
much of a long-term plan but
yeah for sure when i come back to new
zealand and
ideally the next couple of years and new
zealand be awesome to play super
and then yeah
definitely keen to to get back overseas
and have some
new experiences again yeah playing rugby
overseas is it all black's a big goal
for you is that a big carrot for you uh
not not really at the moment like
i guess it's always there a little bit
like
you'd love to get back there and and
anything can happen and i guess i know
that if if i you know can come back and
and play some some good rugby who knows
but
at the moment for me it's just
i just want to come back and play at a
high level and um i know my best foot is
still ahead of me so
um just yeah looking to do that in new
zealand at the moment mate after talking
to beaver a few weeks ago i feel like
this story has a fair bit of beaver
about it and potentially you might be
getting a late call up into the world
cap over in france next year
[Laughter]
maybe i'll just go find a river and go
white baiting somewhere while that's
going on
i'm predicting and i reckon you're gonna
have a massive super rugby next year um
the criticism will probably still be
coming you'll get the call up and you'll
be kicking a winning goal
oh
we will see but uh also life after footy
i know you're only 25 it's a long way
away from for you but
um you've been studying at uni no doubt
you're a very intelligent man what are
your plans yeah finished up at uni
somehow only took me five years to get a
sporting rec degree
but um i guess i've got that to fall
back on and
um just from from school i had like an
awesome teacher and coach and he was
like a mentor for me
and i guess ever since then
i've i've always wanted to be a teacher
and just
i guess have the opportunity to do that
for someone else
um would be awesome so that's that's
probably the only
thing i have at the moment that you know
i have a bit of a passion for how did
you manage to finish your degree i know
a lot of young guys
are trying to study find it really hard
to finish it while they start their
professional rugby career how do you
manage to do that i was probably lucky
just
that my first couple of years down there
i was able to knock off a few like have
a full year study my first year and then
i think maybe did six papers my second
and then
once i was sort of over halfway i just i
thought you know i've got to just keep
chipping away here and just tried to do
a couple of papers a semester maybe one
uh when footy got a bit more full-on but
yeah i was stoked to be able to take
that off in the end no that's that's
massive and no doubt you're going to be
one of the great teachers
we'll be recruiting you to nelson
college
[Laughter]
but as always mate we've gone to the
instagram for some questions and plenty
have come through lots of your ram lads
um lots of turbos um so we'll get
through some of these see what we come
up with but
um why is brett the biggest grub to play
for the rams
ah
i'm definitely not a grub not on the
field anyway
they're probably talking about some
off-field stuff when you know just being
19 and
or any stories
not really
oh there was one
one year we ended up winning the club
title
um and for some reason they always have
the final in christchurch on a sunday
and i had um
i had an exam on monday morning at eight
o'clock i was like
this is going to be a side show and um
we decided to have have to do it our
flat that was our seven man flat off
geordie
so that there was a hell of a doe
people punching holes in the roof and
the walls and all sorts and so i wasn't
gonna get much sleep that night anyway
and then i just remember waking up like
on top of my beard like fully still in
my number one still got my shoes on
and then
i like had my phone and it was ten to
eight
and i was like oh no like under it no
time to get changed
straight in the car straight out to my
exam like 15 minute drive
so i had to like rock into this exam
late and
everyone turns around and sees like me
just in an absolute state and my number
one's like coming in like oh what's this
guy up to
how did you go
yeah luckily it's multi-choice i was
sort of just
you know head spinning just circling
anything
and um
results come back a couple of weeks
later and i got 50 on the dot c minus
you beauty
[Laughter]
oh that is good stuff love that
okay next one um
mention this one a little bit earlier
about crookus rams initiation
oh yeah probably my ear felt pretty
crook when i was getting initiated and
then seeing it the year after was just
as bad but
you're just so scared because you're all
on the flat and they're doing it in the
garage and
the older boys will come in and maybe
take like three at a time or two at a
time and
they'll blindfold you and pull you into
this garage and there's all sorts of
noises going on and
you know you have to get nude for half
of it and then you just
make your way across this table of all
sorts of like cropped drinks and
eating stuff yeah
it wasn't fun
that does sound horrible
19 year old kid welcome
oh good stuff okay next one best jordi
barrett stitch up must be a few of these
from you
um
i'm not sure i can't really think of
too many there'd be a lot but i've been
not throwing them under the bus
oh he's just a shock at like time
management i like i remember in the
halls first year we played
i think it was a preseason game and i
was warming up and we'd always like kick
together in the warm up
and then like he just wasn't there and i
was like oh no like so i sprinted over
to the halls
like banging on his window and the
curtains are shut and he like pulls his
blinds and he's like
like what and i'm like
we're warming up like what are you doing
and he's like [ __ ]
it's so like he runs out like no bricky
just straight changed and like
typical him like still plays well
unbelievable
well that is good like that one classic
classic jordy okay next one do you
purposely tense your quads lining up a
goal kick i've never noticed this but
after looking through some photos maybe
you do
no i definitely don't
i think it's maybe like the same
the same thing that i do as geordie like
we got taught to sort of
go up and had like rock off onto our
toes a couple of times so maybe
i don't know maybe it's there
and maybe a bit of richie who who said
he just wears extra small um shorts
yeah well i kind of have to anyway
because i'm quite short so i'm always in
between
yeah in between sizes so i'm probably am
on a bit of the smaller side
yeah
you either go short and i'm small or
baggy like marty mckenzie
there's a down below his ass and he's
got his socks down he'll sit up
okay next one um uh can you ask him how
many fresh limes he takes around the
golf course
yeah i know who this is from
and
he's good for a stitch up
trying to get out for a casual day on a
you know game of golf on a day off and
he turns up with a box of coronas and a
little tupperware container pre-cut
limes ready to go
is this for the
turbos yeah
oh
how good is that
can hold midweek
okay next one oh this isn't this is the
people's champ here here he comes have
you ever been late to training because
of a big night mid-week same edward
oh yeah i did not get off to a good
start over here
so we had like a bit of a christmas do
and uh i'd only just got here
and it was on a sunday
for some reason and
you know we had had a couple beers with
dinner and
i was always good chance to you know get
to know the foreign boys and
of course old henny he's like yeah no
we'll go we'll take you to this pub down
the road
i'll we'll show you the spots and then
we go out you know a few more keep going
like i've almost just fully forgotten
that we've got a gym in the morning and
just not in a good state and then i've
just missed my alarm
boys are ringing me like where are you
we're in the gym and i'm like
rock up late not a good luck first week
they hate stuff like that too over there
right
yeah somehow i've kind of got away with
it probably copper fine at the end of
the year but
it's lucky but henwood would have been
feeding you all of those strong zeros
and all sorts of um concoctions to get
you absolutely hammered no doubt oh big
time he loves it last time
he turned up with a like backpack full
of just all sorts of crook japanese
beers he's like yeah these go good
what high ball whiskey and soda is
that's like horrific
oh he's a rooster that's for sure
okay next one are you eligible for
another nation with the new stand down
rules ah no i'm not no i haven't got any
affiliations with any other nothing in
that that's right ah that's interesting
any moldy no no
dad works for the maori land court so
we'll say
maybe just a touch
okay next one oh this is from johnny
faroli
how's the yen coming from home this is
this is a big call yeah coming from him
he's been over in japan for how long now
for one for that reason he must be on
big time
nothing on old johnny
how have you found your first or like
your first few yen payments so
always pretty impressive
yeah it is um
yeah it's good good for the headspace if
you're having a rough month and then you
get to the end of the month and payday
rolls across
you're like oh yeah no this is all good
we'll keep going when life gets tough
over there
just refresh the bank account
that goes on to the next one what's the
worst part about living in japan what
have you found um
it's probably just been like the covered
restrictions still like we haven't been
allowed to do too much like i'd love to
get out and explore and
sort of get the full experience but
it's just the way it is at the moment
like
most of the time we haven't even been
able to to go out and eat out so it's
been pretty tough
um in that sense how are you eating what
who's are you cooking yourself or you're
doing the elliot dixon ubereats
yeah no i've been trying to cook for
myself but um yes it's tough cooking for
one every night of the week it is you
get pretty sick of it so
it's fairly basic around here what's
your go to uh i sometimes just whip up
like a big curry and freeze some and
you know then if i can't be bothered i
can just heat that up
living japanese curry
do you like that natto oh no not a fan
eh did you like it yeah awful stuff i
couldn't stand it but some of the boys
got into it eh yeah they love it it
would have been a great snack for um
when you're cooking for one just to
smash back some matter who loves it
henny i don't know why he smashes it he
said it's like a wee dessert for him
yeah any free food for him goes down a
tree
yeah that'll be it
okay next one the next question is from
our sponsors swish if you could get a
video shout out from anyone who would it
be and why
uh
probably tiger woods he's probably my
favorite sportsman
oh yeah
yeah
he's just the goat both absolute grubs
off the field
no way
[Laughter]
okay next one who's the best 10 in world
rugby right now well that's a tough one
eh um
there's a few obviously like bodhi and
richie
that like on their day unreal and then
there's just
like intermec and his combination with
um
the nine in france at the moment it's
pretty unreal as well
who's who would you be picking if you
had to choose one
three good shouts hard to argue
um
i'll go i'll go for rich yeah i thought
you would there it is yeah good call
okay
two more
who's the most influential player in
japanese rugby is that another question
from henny is it
he wants me to say sam hinwood oh this
one might be from damian mckenzie
actually
i don't know i haven't watched like a
lot a lot of the top league stuff so
i probably don't have much to say in
that sense but there's a few good
players here
in the second division like obviously
kwade koopie pretty much
runs the show for
kintetsu so he he's up there in our
division and then
there's a few good foreigners
at mitsubishi have you found it weird
like playing in a competition which you
don't really follow as much as you
normally would yeah yeah it is weird
like you sort of don't really know what
to expect initially
and then
new sort of challenges every week and
it's a bit different but it's cool
coming up against like you know foreign
guys that
you've either played with or or watched
and it's called catching up with them
after the game yeah that's the one thing
you notice when you get over there as a
how many guys um who you haven't seen
for years popping up and all sorts of
japanese leagues and you're playing
against them and you're like oh [ __ ]
that's where you've been for the last
eight years oh
yeah exactly it's crazy okay last
question question i ask everyone always
like to finish on some inspiration and
going from what you've been through oh
this could be the most inspirational out
of them all
best piece of advice
you have for our what are led listeners
well it's always a tough one um
i think
like just what resonates with me the
most is probably just
be patient like this there's just
no point worrying about what other
people are doing around you in terms of
what you want to achieve and
with that just probably like know who
you listen to is a massive one any tips
on being patient obviously a lot of
young guys coming through
always feel like they're in a race
always comparing with other guys from
their age groups or
guys who they might have been in
new zealand 20s with have kicked on a
lot quicker
have you got any techniques you use to
stay patient
yeah i sort of struggled with that a
little bit as well like when i first
moved down to christchurch there were
guys that already signed
npc crusaders contracts and
i just remember talking to my teacher at
school and he just he just kept saying
to me like
you're in you're in the right place just
just do your time and
if you keep setting small goals along
the way and
you know just don't question
you know your work ethic you just got to
work harder and
do everything you can then you know
that's that's really all you can
all you can do but it's crazy how it
catches up like school stuff doesn't
really matter so i guess for young guys
like
you got so much time so yeah
just be patient
mate that is powerful love that what a
way to finish the podcast one of the
great journeys and what a lead you are
as everyone promise me um you have
definitely delivered one of the greats
that teacher sounds like he had a
massive influence on you and
no doubt in the future you're going to
be having that influence on so many
other kids as you finish your rugby
career hopefully kick the winning goal
for the all blacks over in france and
then
life after footy inspiring the next
generation as a school teacher looking
forward to following it mate
i appreciate it um
i love your work and thanks for having
me on it's been um good to have you on
appreciate it all right you're a lad
appreciate it mate cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]
you